[Music]
we have to talk about something right
away that that is of paramount
importance
your wife is due to give birth any day
now yeah she's she's uh she's preggers
and we're about to have our baby she's
supposed to have our baby tonight right
now
is it an issue then that you're here it
is such an issue that I'm here right now
for me not for her like she wanted me to
be here she knows how important being on
Conan is and so she's like you know you
got to go to Conan and I'm like baby no
I can't go do Conan she's like no no no
you got to do Conan and I'm like no baby
I'm not going to do Conan there's no way
I'm going to do these are the
conversations you have with her even
when she's not pregnant but but Wow so
it's supposed to happen I got my
cellphone on me right here just in case
and so she do you mind if I put it right
here not at all all right coach now
that's all I'm thinking about so if that
goes off I might have to leave okay well
as you see we're right by the bay so
yeah I can't tell you almost slipped and
said that okay
well listen we're all thinking good
thoughts thank you and very excited for
you thank you folks move on speaking of
cellphones I understand that you
photobombed one of the biggest
celebrities in the world recently is
that true yes wanna talk about that sure
let's talk about let's get into it
okay I photobomb Tom Cruise you
photobomb Tom Cruise kind of audience
reply
like you shouldn't mess around with him
what have you done can we see this for
work I mean did you did because I was
Tom Cruise and I know you're not
necessarily supposed to mess with Tom
Cruise and Hollywood you just don't do
that I know a lot of you seen oblivion a
lot of you seen Mission Impossible you
know he could fight real well right and
I made the mistake about thank goodness
he didn't run up on me because that
would have been really awkward but I
made the mistake of photobomb and Tom
Cruise
okay can we see can we see it I don't
have it on my phone oh oh wait I think
we do we have it somewhere else there it
is
[Applause]
that came out perfectly